this video was made possible by hover
get 10 off your first purchase of a
custom domain or email address at
hover.com
wendover covid19 that's the answer
that's what caused all the shortages of
2020 and 2021. that's it
kova 19 caused these shortages in the
same way that an iceberg
caused the titanic to sink or the
collapse of lehman brothers caused the
great recession
or the straw broke the camel's back
that's really to say
kovid did cause these shortages they
would not have happened in the manner
they did
when they did if not for the pandemic
but just as the titanic's design flaws
would eventually lead to calamity
the vulnerabilities in the global
economy would eventually lead to a
recession
and something would eventually break the
overloaded camel's back
kovid caused these shortages but it's
not
what made them possible what made them
possible
is a fundamental structural
vulnerability
in the way today's supply chains work
on april 13th 2021 boba bliss
a small bubble tea shop in dublin
california posted
on facebook they explained they were
having a hard time getting their
ingredients
and that this would mean their menu
would have to change daily reflective of
what they could actually get from their
supplier
on april 15th mighty boba in canada new
york
explained on facebook that they would
have to serve a smaller quantity of
tapioca
pearls in each drink and would no longer
be offering extra as an option
due to a shortage of this ingredient
bing's boba tea in tucson arizona said
much the same one week later
and t hut in san francisco california
then announced that they would have to
raise their prices
due to a 26 rise in their ingredient
costs
all across the country shops selling
this popular taiwanese drink
simply could not get ingredients in the
quantities demanded
despite no dramatic increase in demand
however thousands of miles away in
taiwan
where much of the world's bubble tea
ingredients are made things were
operating
fairly normally with single-digit daily
case numbers for much of kovitz reign
factories on the island were able to
work at full force in a way they
couldn't elsewhere
but still somehow boba bliss mighty boba
bing's boba tea t-hut and thousands of
other shops across the u.s
couldn't get their product the problem
had less to do with anything happening
in taiwan
and more with what was happening here in
the waters
off the coast of los angeles throughout
the first half of 2021
a rotating cast of dozens of cargo ships
have dotted the pacific's horizon
each sat there at anchor sometimes for
weeks
until a spot opened for them at the port
of los angeles or long beach
this is abnormal while the year prior it
was possible for a ship or two to have
to wait a day or two
it was never dozens of ships for dozens
of days
transit time from taiwan to los angeles
typically takes about two weeks
so an additional 10 days of waiting
represents a near doubling
of shipping times the root cause of this
was
of course a perfect pandemic fueled
storm as the 2020 holiday season
approached
more people were getting back to work in
the u.s consumer spending was ticking up
and online shopping was exploding with
limited access to travel
restaurants shows and other services
physical products were one of the few
ways people could spend their
discretionary income
more goods than ever were coming from
factories in asia
and 49.1 percent of those imports to the
us
passed through one of just two ports
los angeles and long beach compared to a
year prior
before coveted hit the u.s in earnest
february 2021 saw a
31 increase in ships and a 49 increase
in container traffic
at these two ports they just couldn't
keep up simultaneously however
a significant tranche of dock workers
were constantly out sick due to covet
itself
or the quarantine procedures it demanded
but the disorder
doesn't end there while a year ago a
20-foot container would cost about 1800
they now run for 3500. there's a
regional shortage of shipping containers
that's having global consequences
you see in 2020 just as much of the
world entered lockdowns
china's manufacturing industry was
emerging from it
the entire world bought masks personal
protective equipment
and regular goods from the country and
once those containers arrived in ports
like long beach
they were unloaded however due to those
destination countries lockdowns
there wasn't really much that needed to
be shipped out
for every 100 containers that are
imported into the us
only 40 are exported so
containers stacked up in the places they
weren't needed because they weren't
needed
and they didn't make it back to places
where they were like asia
in the case of the ports of los angeles
and long beach their capacity crunch
means they don't even have the time to
justify loading ships with empty
containers for return to asia
not only that but a shortage of truck
drivers in the u.s
means that it's tough to actually get
empty containers back from their final
destinations
to ports to send them back to asia so
a shortage of shipping containers is
worsening a shortage of shipping
capacity which is worsened by a shortage
of port capacity
which is worsening the shortage of
shipping containers which itself is
worsened by a shortage of truck drivers
all of which is causing a shortage of
bubble tea ingredients
shortages causing shortages causing
shortages
it's a vicious cycle that is only
worsening as economies reopen
across the world there's a proliferation
of scarcity lumber prices in the u.s
quadrupled after a predicted decline
failed to manifest
and a boom in construction and
renovation did instead
the use and construction of pools also
accelerated as outdoor spaces became
more valuable
spurring increased demand for chlorine
which when mixed with reduced supply as
a result of a fire at a major chlorine
plant in louisiana
led to sky-high prices and insufficient
availability
as restaurants pivoted to takeout and
delivery bulk ketchup was out and
single-serve packets were in
but with manufacturers unwilling to
spend significantly to increase
production capacity for a short-term
bump
the packets became scarce and companies
started successfully selling them for 10
per 50 on ebay however the greatest
shortage of
all can be seen here in the empty
parking lots
of anchorage alaska's airport the state
relies heavily on its summer tourism
season and after missing it last year
2021 season is crucial facing
uncertainty about the legality of their
operation until may
cruise companies cancelled many of their
summer sailings to alaska
so this year is all about independent
domestic
tourists to traverse the vast wilderness
of the last frontier
independent travelers need rental cars
however these travelers can't get rental
cars
regardless of which date you search in
summer 2021
there simply isn't availability for the
lucky few who do find one
current market rates are over 500 a day
for a compact car american travelers can
now
legally safely and easily go to alaska
but they can't get around alaska
which means that eager travelers aren't
going
you see during the depths of the
pandemic hertz enterprise
national and other rental car companies
sold off much of their fleets of cars
they needed money somehow and it wasn't
coming from rentals themselves
now however with vaccinations easily
available to
all in the u.s there is demand for
rentals
yet no supply in alaska especially
with its highly seasonal tourism market
it's normal for the rental car companies
to sell off their old vehicles in the
fall
and purchase new ones in spring the
latter half of that
didn't happen this year because there's
a massive global shortage of new cars
and manufacturers are simply unable to
fulfill the huge orders
rental car companies are asking for you
see
in spring 2020 as kova took hold of the
globe
car manufacturers canceled and reduced
their orders for components
as they anticipated reduced demand for
new vehicles they were right
on that demand did go down as it tends
to during any recession
but it recovered faster than anyone
imagined
regardless the plan was that once
recovery started
they'd boost component orders and
manufacturing in step
the problem was that they're now at the
back of the line and for one
critical component of modern automobiles
there's quite
a long line computer chips
are sold out everywhere it was the
perfect storm
of circumstances first the us's trade
war with china
caused the country's manufacturers to
start stockpiling the chips
then covet led to production shutdowns
in certain areas of the world
demand for consumer electronics exploded
as people spent more time at home
and now even the solution is causing
problems as silicon is both needed in
computer chips
and vaccine vials altogether the reasons
are complex
but the result is clear this is why you
still can't easily buy a ps5
this is why samsung likely won't release
a new galaxy smartphone this year
and this is why you can't get a rental
car in alaska
in a twist of cruel irony the car
industry
is culpable for all of this that's
because
decades ago the very industry that is
now suffering the hardest
propagated the system that made
shortages such as this
so possible 80 years ago
as japan emerged from world war ii
toyota
had a problem the world was marching
towards further globalization
and japan especially was starting to
develop a trade relationship with the
u.s
american car manufacturers at the time
though had a
huge cost edge over their japanese
counterparts
especially during the post-war economic
boom demand for their vehicles was
so high that american manufacturers had
incredible
economies of scale their process
was batch manufacturing at a given time
a given assembly line would build one
type
of one model of one vehicle exclusively
then they'd switch to another type of
another model and so on and so forth
with this the manufacturers could use
massive production lines working at
breakneck pace
unlike toyotas theirs were small
and slow the domestic car market in
japan was limited and it demanded quite
a lot of variety
in vehicle types this meant that they
didn't have the scale to make batch
manufacturing work well
at least as well as in the us their
inability to realize the gains of batch
manufacturing meant they simply would
have to have higher prices compared to
their new american competitors
but there just wasn't a clear
alternative
so they created one they created
the toyota production system it had
two core principles starting with
automation
not automation autonomation it was
their term for the efficient use of
automation
now complete automation would require
machines to build cars
plus diagnose any problems plus fix
those problems
but having machines fix their own
problems is very complicated
and very expensive so in their
autonomation system
they look for only what machines can do
better than humans which in their
context was
most of vehicle assembly and problem
diagnosis while problem solving was left
to humans autonomation was and still
is a crucial critical component of the
toyota production system
but it wasn't the core principle that
would go on to change manufacturing
fundamentally what did was the principle
of just in time manufacturing all it
really is
is this each step in the manufacturing
process should end
when the next one is ready to start it's
a pull system
as opposed to a push system just as your
coffee shop doesn't start making your
latte until you ask for it
the polyvinyl butyrole resin should only
leave the chemicals plant when the
laminated safety glass production
facility is ready to start making
windshields
and it should only start making
windshields when the final assembly line
is ready to put all the pieces together
and it should only start putting all the
pieces together when the dealership is
ready to put more cars on its lot
in the view of the toyota production
system excess inventory is a waste
because holding inventory costs money
without
making money elimination of excess
inventory is elimination of waste
and elimination of waste is what leads
to production efficiency
this system worked in the early 1950s
toyota was on the brink of bankruptcy
today
the company is the largest auto
manufacturer in the world and the
principles of the toyota production
system can be found in
any business textbook just in time
manufacturing is no longer an innovation
it's the norm articles aren't written
about companies implementing just in
time
they're written about those that don't
in fact
just in time has become even more
integral today
if there are six steps in the
manufacturing process and each holds two
months of inventory
it would take a year to pivot to
producing a new product
the short product life cycles of today's
technology industry
would not accept that just in time it's
such a simple principle
but the pursuit of the elimination of
waste is now the central mission
of any major manufacturer however
most did it wrong
manufacturers globally saw the headline
elimination of inventory leads to
massive efficiency gains
and jumped on that without actually
determining what made it work for toyota
they ignored that japan's small physical
size made for short domestic supply
chains
less vulnerable to things going wrong
they ignored the company's production
leveling
finding the average daily demand and
producing that regardless of short-term
changes and demands
they ignore the fact that eliminating
excess inventory is different from
eliminating
all inventory they ignore the principle
of growing strong teams of
cross-functional workers
predicated on respecting people they
ignore the culture of stopping and
fixing problems to get things right the
first time
they ignored huge swaths of the toyota
way and created a system that's less
effective
and less resilient but can impress
shareholders through short-term
savings how toyota has effectively
implemented this system
fills books but many are just reading
the covers even toyota though
is not perfect in 2011 japan was rocked
by a 9.0 magnitude earthquake
the fourth strongest ever recorded
anywhere
not only did this cause immense
destruction to life and property but it
also led toyota to recognize a flaw
in its own system as japan recovered
some supply chains were quick to as well
for example
securing plastic resin for door panel
production is not difficult
there are plenty of manufacturers
globally creating easily substitutable
alternatives
that's not the case with say
semiconductors
the hugely expensive facilities that
create these chips require
years to construct and after the 2011
earthquake
it took many months to mend them back to
operating status
this surfaced a truth that had never
been fully considered
not all supply chains are made equal
plastic resin can handle supply chain
disruption
semiconductors cannot therefore
toyota made changes all along
their mission was not to eliminate
inventory full stop
it was to eliminate excess inventory
supply chain disruption is inevitable
it's inevitable in the same way that
titanic's flawed design would eventually
encounter an iceberg
or the structural economic
vulnerabilities of 2008 would eventually
collide with a market panic
therefore semiconductor inventory is not
excess
because inevitably due to the
inevitability of disruption
excess semiconductor inventory will
eventually become
necessary recognizing this toyota
in recent years has started to build up
a stockpile of two to six months worth
of chips
and that's why the company is the only
major vehicle manufacturer that is
unfazed by the semiconductor shortage
toyota followed its own principles it
did not stray from them
and it did not reinvent them it's no
surprise that toyota excels at
implementing its own system
but it is a surprise that the entire
manufacturing world has so
wholeheartedly embraced flawed
implementation of the system
the reality is that just-in-time
manufacturing is more efficient
but some think that that efficiency must
come with a trade-off
in resilience that's simply not true
proper just-in-time supply chains must
inherently be inflexible once formed
but their form is flexible it's a
philosophy
not an equation shortages in an economy
are incredibly complex
and any explanation of them is an
oversimplification but just in time
manufacturing
does not have to be the cause in
addition disruption
is inevitable so it can't be the cause
you can't blame the fact that your house
is sinking on the fact that you built it
in the ocean a ruthless pursuit of
short-term profit at the expense of a
long-term
gain is the cause running as close as
possible to the edge is the most
efficient manner to manufacture
until it isn't constructing a resilient
supply chain requires long-term thinking
but most companies have not nurtured an
environment that allows for that
as the world recovers from the pandemic
many will ditch what they call
just-in-time manufacturing
as the alternative is to accept that the
very people in charge of those companies
haven't implemented it properly to be
fair
few have and even toyota is still
learning how to best implement
its own system however toyota has proven
that
strict adherence to its principles means
just-in-time manufacturing can be
everything at once it can be both
efficient and resilient
if one knows what is truly excess
proper implementation of the toyota
system won't fix every shortage
but it did fix one shortage for one
company
therefore if the auto industry had built
a stockpile of critical components
if it had implemented production
leveling more strictly and if it had
understood vulnerabilities in inbound
supply chains
alaska would have its rental cars
unlike the world of physical goods it's
impossible to manufacture
new website domains once one is gone
it's gone for good therefore that's why
whenever i have a new idea for a youtube
channel
a podcast or anything my first step is
to buy the domain on hover
their transparent straightforward and
fair pricing means that i know i'm
getting a good deal
and it's pretty important to have your
domain secured if whatever you're doing
has a chance of growing
if i didn't get the
wendoverproductions.com domain i'm sure
someone would have snatched it up
as soon as the channel grew i use that
not only for the website itself
but also for email hover lets you set up
a custom email address at a custom
domain
in quite literally seconds and now when
i send emails to someone i want to
interview for example
they see that it's from a professional
looking address rather than one ending
in gmail
yahoo or icloud and i have a better
chance of success
to grab your domain before it's gone and
set up a professional custom email
address
all for 10 off head to hover.comwendover
and you'll be helping support the
channel
while you're at it